I can target anyone some hacker is  hitting all financial markets to catch  this guy we're gonna need a black hat  hacker named Hathaway he's a genius  coder serving 15 years if you want my  assistance I want you to commute my  sentence locate this guy okay you get  discovered you're dead meat section is  code right here is a mess he's still  renting the moment you connect you lose  control someone had the physically enter  this room for diversion it's only the  beginning  he's still running  move around within this cold  he's on the move again Chicago Nell  playing the guy we're working will drop  the big hammer and not think twice about  it this isn't about money this isn't  about politics  I can talk  see  anywhere